are you excited that it looks like
Michael Bloomberg is running for
president that has excite you Wow
right now Bloomberg is watching oh no I
bet he's paying someone to watch who
will lie to it yeah yeah well that was
why I just took my own instant poll yeah
he's screwed yeah he should get out now
Cohen just asked his audience and they
said no destroy a Conan he's a little
cat that's what that is
what did you think it was looks like
he's running Michael Bloomberg has now
filed to be on the ballot in Alabama and
Arkansas yeah
sources say in those two states he's all
but locked up the Jewish voter the North
thank you
the guys name is Saul we actually vh1
people were on vh1 just announced a new
reality show starring the wife the wife
of Mexican drug cartel leader El Chapo
vh1 signed her up for show yeah the show
was called we were afraid to say no
what a mining here Wow
like someone was shot I think they went
to the big sub sandwich yeah JetBlue
just unrolled a new no-frills service
called basic blue yeah
then today United unrolled its no-frills
service called United the quarter that
not my favorite
like I've had that experience true true
but not so many that I'll laugh a
moderate amount